bonsoir le 7-8 l'aktu sur tv fil 78
l'essentiel de l'information locale
comme chaque soir à 18h en direct et
voici les titres de ce mercredi à
trappes coup d'envoi de la concertation
préalable de la population avant le
chantier de l'enfouissement d'une partie
de la nationale 10 le président de
l'université chinoise a reçu la presse
afin d'expliquer la situation financière
de son établissement lui vécu présenté
au bord de la cessation de paiement ces
derniers jours et puis journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant
lui en cours y participent activement
marie-christine le tarnec adjointe au
maire et va taleb mère enfant de la
ville seront à les invités de ce journal
l image du jour elle peut surprendre ce
sont des comédiens déguisés en poussins
notamment ou encore mère noël vous allez
les apercevoir c'est pour une bonne
cause attirer l'attention et pouvoir
évoquer la réduction des déchets avec
les clients de ce supermarché de
montigny le bretonneux ils sont membres
de l'association pic pic et incite les
gens à consommer en veillant à la
gestion des emballages cette semaine est
consacrée en europe à la réduction des
déchets de 1700 opérations sont prévues
à travers l'hexagone aujourd'hui chacun
de nous produit en moyenne 590 kg de
déchets deux fois plus qu'il ya 40 ans
on écoute le directeur des services
techniques de montigny le bretonneux la
ville à l'origine de cette opération
d'aujourd'hui la ville a souhaité
organiser cette manifestation en
partenariat avec l'association pit pit
qui va donc
indiquer aux gens des éco gestes pour
réduire les déchets et réduire aussi le
gaspillage alimentaire c'est la première
opération de ce type d'autres opérations
ont lieu tous les ans dans ce cadre et
vous comment gérez-vous au quotidien vos
déchets c'est notre question du jour vos
réponses au micro de michael jarrell je
trie mes déchets etc les emballages le
verre et les ordures ménagères et un
petit compost pour les tout ce qui est
déchets de table en fin de fruits et
légumes qui reste j'évite aussi les
plats cuisinés on achète les on achète
un phénomène donc sa fin au moins
d'emballage je trie en fait le vert les
papiers cartons et puis le reste des
ordures ménagères dans trois containers
différent il ya des poubelles sélectives
dans notre résidence donc c'est pas un
problème on descend les verts les
papiers les emballages voilà on fait le
tri des déchets norme où tous les jours
à la maison du carton le verre les puits
donc on utilise toutes les poubelles qui
sont donnés par la communauté de
communes ou encore par l'agglomération
je respecte scrupuleusement à ce qu'on
me dit de faire avec de temps en temps
des petits des pizzas entorse quand j'ai
pas le temps c'est pas très compliqué
c'est pas très dur à faire et puis si ça
peut permettre de faire plaisir à
monsieur le maire et à toute concession
suis ravi
toujours autour de cette thématique la
société eco emballages qui assure le
pilotage du dispositif national de tri
et de recyclage mais des emballages
ménagers vient de changer de directeur
régional olivier leclercq en 2014 son
objectif est d'augmenter de 2% soit 5500
tonnes de matières recyclées
supplémentaire pour l'île de france et
des milliers de véhicules qui traversent
chaque jour la ville des riverains qui
n'espéraient plus d'améliorations et
pourtant attrape le projet
d'enfouissement de la nationale 10 est
bel et bien lancée avec une nouvelle
phase la concertation qui démarre ce
mercredi elle se déroule jusqu'au 20
décembre catherine de la torre
du haut du balcon de la mairie guy
malandain pointe du doigt l'endroit du
futur plateau urbain qui couvrira la
nationale 10 depuis un an et demi la
mairie de trappes a la certitude que le
projet de 100 millions d'euros
d'enfouissement de la nationale sera
bien financé aujourd'hui l'heure est à
la concertation d'états menés jusqu'au
20 décembre
l'étape la plus importante récemment il
ya un an et demi maintenant c'est la
concertation organisée par la ville sur
le plateau urba commencera dessus quand
la route passera dessous aujourd'hui
demain que commence la concertation
menée par l'état sur les travaux
routiers
ici les habitants peuvent donner leur
avis aux variantes leur sont proposés
rien que cela met une retient plus
particulièrement l'attention de la
municipalité
la variante un acquis en terre la
nationale 10 au niveau du pavillon bleu
jusqu'à la station bp honda des grands
ronds points à ceux tricolore un petit
cadence la circulation et la route qui
vient de dreux qui passe devant la base
de loisirs comme la route qui vient qui
vient d'elancourt et et qui s'appelle
martin luther qui passe de sous pour
aller rejoindre vers paris et puis au
milieu de tout ça nous devons la mairie
pour aller vite on à la route qui est
enfoui descendu un tube elle en gros et
qui est couvert par ce qu'on appelle un
plateau journée sitôt suit son cours
lanka public pourrait avoir lieu au
premier semestre 2014 avant le premier
coup de pioche fin 2016 un dossier qui
aura eu raison des plus patient la ville
a commencé à réfléchir à l'aménagement
de cette nationale de
1998 chaque jour cette route est
emprunté par 70 mille véhicules
un ancien ministre du logement présent à
trappes justement hier soir l'actuel
député de la marne benoist apparu a
échangé avec des locataires des squares
lagrange védrine thorez ou encore
langevin un échange programmé à part le
candidat divers droite aux prochaines
municipales otsmane massrour
trappe et c'est chantier de nouveaux
logements qui sortent de terre
régulièrement mais au milieu de ses
réalisations des locataires des
quartiers plus anciens qui se sentent
abandonnés
mardi soir à trappes ce sont ses
habitants justement être des squares
lagrange védrine thorez qui se sont
réunis pour évoquer les difficultés
qu'ils rencontrent actuellement entre
charges en hausse avec et des
régularisations pour la consommation
d'eau de plusieurs milliers d'euros et
des problèmes d'insalubrité il ya un
locataire qui a vraiment des champignons
c'est important on dirait qu'il a
proposé sous c'était quoi c'est de
mettre des plaques de mettre des plaques
excusez moi pour l'expression mais si on
est salon va pas mais des vêtements
propres bon nombre avant des aides pour
savoir où on peut taper pour être relogé
parce que l'ensemble est enceinte on a
déjà une petite fille on à l'appartement
est rôti et est jugée par les services
d'hygiène de la mairie en salle du bois
et ses résidents on aurait à ce jour pas
réussi à construire un échange avec les
bailleurs sociaux valophis et effi dix
candidats aux municipales othman nassr
ou divers droite dénonce pour moi
attrape les bailleurs aujourd'hui ne met
pas beaucoup de zèle à prendre leurs
responsabilités
oui et je crois que c'est le rôle des
pouvoirs publics la municipalité va
comité d'agglomération le conseil
général conseil régional mettre la
pression sur ses bailleurs qui prennent
leurs responsabilités bonne fois pour
toutes c'est à travers un collectif qui
le mobilise aujourd'hui trappe citoyens
collectif qui a reçu la visite de
benoist apparu l'ancien ministre au
logement je ne suis évidemment pas
décisionnaire pour régler leurs
problèmes au quotidien simplement j'ai
souhaité répondre à l'invitation de
notre candidat pour rencontrer au plus
proche du terrain ceux qui ont des
problèmes au quotidien dans leur
organisme hlm avec leur organisation m
pour essayer un les écouter les entendre
et essayer de leur apporter des réponses
les locataires pense aujourd'hui à mener
d'autres actions devant la justice mais
aussi dans la rue
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines peut souffler
son président obtenu du ministère une
rallonge budgétaire de 4 millions
d'euros le montant du déficit un plan de
réduction des dépenses drastiques va se
mettre en place d'ici 2014 dans les
prochains mois est les syndicats restent
vigilants
jean-luc vestiaire était resté
silencieux ces derniers jours le
président de l'université de versailles
saint quentin est sorti de sa réserve ce
mercredi pour annoncer que le ministère
avait accordé une rallonge de 4 millions
d'euros le montant du déficit de l' us
j'aurais souhaité avoir un peu plus j'ai
pu obtenir donc de la souplesse qui
permet à
l'université de north et donc des
factures aux petits fournisseurs de
honoré de nouveaux engagements
contractuels avec des partenaires
notamment étrangers des partenaires de
recherche est également des engagements
pour permettre de faire fonctionner les
formations d'ici la fin de l'année une
rallonge qui s'assortit d'un plan de
retour à l'équilibré en trois ans à
hauteur de 7 millions d'euros cela va
commencer dès 2014 avec une réduction de
dépenses de 4 millions dont 3 millions
rien que pour la masse salariale y a pas
de licenciements donc ça c'est un
objectif pour moi important ne pas
licencier des contractuels ne l'est pas
les fragiliser comment s'y prend temps
donc on a dit jeanne l'emploi nous avons
eu nous avons obtenu 21 emplois dans le
cadre du plan de la ministre en 2013
nous avons publié que si l'emploi est
ensuite donc on restreint les
recrutements si on licencie pas par
contre on limite les recrutements dont
on restructure au niveau des services
aussi au niveau des services des
directions dévastée donc ça c'est pas le
volet formation il va donc falloir se
serrer la ceinture les masters ne
seraient pas concernés certains parcours
dans les licences seraient eux restreint
mais d'où vient ce déficit le syndicat
snuipp dénoncent les partenariats
public-privé trop coûteux pour
l'université signé notamment pour la
construction de l'ufr des sciences à
montigny le syndicat demande une
commission denquête pourrait étudier ces
contrats la prochaine étape c'est le
vote du budget 2014 début décembre la
des relations toujours difficiles entre
la mairie de guyancourt et l'association
des musulmans de la commune fin octobre
la mairie diffusé un communiqué pour
évoquer des méthodes jugées
inadmissible l'association a tenu à
réagir a évoqué un projet et qui lui
tient à coeur catherine viau l'atome ils
sont venus occuper la mairie sont venus
faire du chantage de
de prières dans la rue ils ont affiché
dans la mosquée d des tracts contre la
mairie donc nous on veut bien dialoguer
mais si le dialogue il commence par ce
genre de rapport de force on va pas
avancer dans ce reportage diffusé fin
octobre benoît ferrer faisait part de
tension entre la mairie et l'association
des musulmans de guyancourt dont le
nouveau bureau a été constitué le 1er
mai dernier une association par la voix
de son président qui réfute toutes les
accusations
je n'ai jamais tenu des propos anti
républicain jamais jamais jamais et ni
afficher denis distribuer des tracts qui
justement pourrait évoquer ce genre de
propos anti revue antirépublicain des
tensions nées notamment autour de
problèmes d'horaires d'ouverture d'une
salle municipale qui leur sert de lieu
de prière et de rassemblement des
tensions qui d'ailleurs avait entraîné
l'arrêt du projet d'agrandissement du
local local a prêté à l'association par
la ville depuis 1990 demain ce que
souhaiterait la mg c'est avoir leurs
propres lieux de culte c'est un projet
qui est en cours parce que je me dis bon
je pense que là
vivre dans l'assistanat un certain
moment bien que l'on remercie justement
les élus de notre commune pour pour le
prêt de la salle nous envisageons de
construire justement
je dirais un lieu de culte pour
justement stopper cette astuce un
assistanat tout simplement une autonomie
et bien sûr ça se fera dans le respect
de l'erreur des lois de la république
pour l'heure le projet en est juste au
stade de la réflexion
deux invités dans le set suite l'actus
ce soir main et christine le tarnec
bonsoir à vous êtes adjointe au maire de
guyancourt sur les questions de
l'enfance du scolaire et du périscolaire
et puis face à vous et vala taleb
bonsoir tu as 13 ans mère enfant de
guyancourt aujourd'hui à 20 novembre
journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant et vous le savez ils sont loin
d'être respectées à travers le monde où
va tout d'abord elle s'intéressait à ton
statut de mère enfant mère des enfants
sur lui en cours ça constitue ça
consiste en quoi que quel est le rôle
d'un maire à ton âge
présenté
au conseil municipal des enfants les
jeunes et montrer qu'on existe en tant
que citoyen en tant que citoyen tu as
été élu il a fallu faire campagne pour
ça comme les adultes ça se passe de la
même manière ça se passait à peu près de
manière bon la campagne est moins longue
mais oui il ya un vote et d comment on
mène campagne alors leur a dit quoi aux
élèves pour qu'ils votent pour toi et
bien pour d'abord moi j'ai été élu
conseiller municipal
donc pour ça j'ai fait ma profession de
foi et après j'ai été élu par les
conseillers donc à vote et pour ça je
leur ai expliqué que c'était mon
deuxième mandat et que j'avais de
l'expérience et que c'était peut-être
moins la plus la plus apte à devenir
mère enfant j'avais un programme de
réalisation à mener non j'ai pas
vraiment de programme j'ai juste dit que
j'étais je pouvais les représenter que
j'étais à petit et on fait confiance à
christine le tarnec adjointe au maire
pourquoi mettre en place un tel de poste
de maire enfants parce que les enfants
je pense qu'il ya un moment ils ont
besoin aussi d'avoir quelqu'un qui leur
présentent ils n'ont pas tous envie de
se mettre en avant et puis il va
participer à toute la vie municipale
elle accompagne le maire pour des
inaugurations en état les raviver la
flamme du tombeau du soldat inconnu de
nombreux soldats inconnus donc elle
était à côté de monsieur le maire pour
déposer une gerbe au nom des enfants
monsieur le maire au nom de la ville et
c'est important parce que ça les
valorise aussi et eva et dans toutes les
manifestations avec nous et du adultes à
côté de nous adultes et nous on aime
bien aussi la voir à lille avec son
écharpe comme nous à nos côtés ça ils
ont des responsabilités ils sont
consultés sur des dossiers ils mènent
des réalisations ils ont un budget
commencera à l'horizon un budget sont et
un budget de 15 mille euros par an donc
c'est quand même relativement important
moitié quête investissement appuie
moitié effectivement fonctionnement et
puis ils ont des projets puisqu'ils sont
élus sur des professions de foi et nous
on regarde la profession de foi donc au
début au début du mandat on discute avec
eux et on leur dit ben voilà puisque des
fois ils savent pas forcément ce qui se
passe déjà dans la ville puisqu'ils sont
ils ont beau être acteurs de la ville
mais connaître ce qui se passe dans leur
quartier pas forcément ce qui se passe
sur le reste de la ville donc il ya déjà
des réalisations des fois qu'ils sont ré
qui sont faites donc on leur explique on
va leur montrer et puis après bien on
sélectionne avec ed
des poètes des projets aura débuté quand
s'achève à l'année dernière elle
s'achève l'année prochaine donc puisque
c'est un mandat de deux ans il ya trente
cinq jeunes conseillers comme à peu près
comme le même nombre que les adultes
puisqu'on est à peu près la même chose
et puis ça va s'achever l'année
prochaine on va ravoir de nouvelles
élections au mois de juin 2014 areva
quelles sont les réalisations que vous
avez mené toi qui est depuis deux
mandats c'est ton deuxième mandat oui si
le premier en tant que maire mais le
deuxième mandat le premier en tant que
maire oui
on a en a pas et on a fait un projet sur
le tri sélectif ont
ça c'est des petits projets on a fait
des gros projets sur par exemple là pour
écouter les toilettes
sur une carte géographique pour pour les
enfants pour marquer ce qui les
intéresse peu et non pas ce qui
intéresse les adultes et
c'est difficile de faire de la politique
quand il a découvert les institutions un
petit peu oui c'est difficile ça se
retourne toujours contre nous de manière
contrôlée de la politique
et on ne va aussi faire aménager les
cours de récré ou à partie des
réalisations vous avez mené plus plus
globalement cette ville de guyancourt
soucie beaucoup d enfants vous mener
toute une politique autour des enfants
des droits de l'enfant également puisque
ça leur permet de découvrir les
institutions ça leur permet de découvrir
leurs droits leurs devoirs c'est ce que
vous faites depuis depuis une dizaine
d'années il ya une journée spécifique
qui sera dédié aux droits de l'enfant
d'ailleurs dans la commune vous êtes
aujourd'hui au niveau international ce
sera vendredi survient alors
effectivement nous le conseil municipal
des enfants se fait plus de vingt ans
qu'il existe sur la commune de
guyancourt parce qu'on pensait que
c'était important que les enfants et la
parole il le doit aussi à la parole ils
sont acteurs de leur ville nous on peut
avoir des choses
les adultes alors proposé mais qui sont
pas forcément un pardon qui sont pas
parents forcément ce que souhaite donc
c'est important de leur donner la parole
et puis comme disait va tout à l'heure
ça permet des deux citoyens de devenir
un citoyen et ça fait plus de dix ans
que sur la vie de guyancourt on a en
propose une journée complète sur sur les
droits de l'enfant donc ça fait dix ans
cette année on a choisi comme thématique
dix ans dix droits fondamentaux donc
qu'ils peuvent être effectivement le
droit d'être enfant le droit à la santé
le droit à l'éducation
et c'est des ateliers conte proposé une
vingtaine d'ateliers à propose ceux qui
sont proposés vendredi prochain pour
l'ensemble des classes de cm1 et de cm2
dans cm1 cm2 et 6e para conseil
municipal des enfants des idées qui sont
effectivement dans les classes et qui
vont effectivement participé à
différents ateliers nous allons faire
juste une petite pause on va parler du
programme de cette journée justement
vous nous avez accordé l'accès à l'une
des classes dans un centre de loisirs
dans votre commune nous sommes allés
voir si le message autour de ces droits
de l'enfant passait bien les enfants
connaissent t-il leurs droits le
reportage d' anthony rech un enfant
n'est pas seulement un être fragile
qu'il faut protéger c'est aussi une
personne qui a le droit d'être éduqué
quel que soit l'endroit du monde où il
est né c'est le message de cet atelier
dans ce centre de loisirs il ya des
enfants dans notre pays qui n'ont pas
l'éducation et qu'ils ont donné à voir
et que
donc nous on a de la chance d'avoir tous
d'avoir un loyer une famille
c'est en chanson que ces jeunes saint
quentinois prennent conscience de la
chance qu'ils ont il paie qui tenez
bailly y a pas de choses parce que là
pas grand chose alors que nous on a
beaucoup de choses cia john
gilroy d'avoir directement avant
d'avoir à manger
lorsque l'on a des droits il ya
forcément des choses interdites et là
aussi le respect de l'autre semble
capital et j'ai pas le droit de me
bagarrer j'ai pas loin de dj d'insulter
les gens j'ai pas le droit de maltraiter
les autres mais lorsqu'on parle aux
enfants de voir la réponse est unanime l
école m'a par exemple de faire mon
travail si tu le fais pas j'aimerais
bien un devoir c'est d'aller à l'école
pour travailler et meurent un travail
plus tard jouer dont la chambre lire
regarder la télévision font partie des
loisirs de ces lui en courtois un luxe
que certains enfants ne connaissent pas
alors ils ont la solution que les
pinèdes
n avec l'argent qu'ils ont et faisant du
bénévolat c'est quand tu apportes de de
la nourriture aux autres et des légendes
difficulté leur offrir un toile célia
aimerait devenir médecin elle pourra
peut-être guérir des enfants dans
d'autres pays en difficulté
selon l'insee en france en 2010 près
d'un enfant sur cinq vivaient sous le
seuil de pauvreté
le message passe bien auprès des enfants
célia bien retenu la leçon oui oui sur
le bénévolat nonis extraordinaire bravo
bravo comment va se passer cette journée
du 22 novembre puisque vous y est vous
l'avez piloter avec le conseil municipal
des enfants sa phase caractérisée
comment les les élèves de hong kong
disait cm1 cm2 6e 17e - et dissiper
elles vont pouvoir faire quoi
donc effectivement c'est sous forme
d'ateliers on a plusieurs partenaires
qui suivent le conseil municipal des
enfants déjà depuis de nombreuses années
comme l'unicef puisque lui en cours et
ville amie des enfants et à la
défenseuse des droits de l'enfant si il
ya l'ipea institut de promotion de la
santé la maison d'ajc des droits dont
faisant plus d'une dizaine donc je suis
désolé je vais pas tous les citer parce
que je vais en oublier donc les ateliers
vont prendre plusieurs formes alors ça
peut être soit des discussions par
exemple l'association artisans du monde
va proposer un film sur la fabrication
d'un ballon au bangladesh fait par les
enfants dans sa part permet de parler du
droit à la protection et contre
l'exploitation des enfants on à
l'association du fun pour tous ceux là
qui a qui travaillent avec des enfants
autistes qui va faire une
sensibilisation aux différents handicaps
la police municipale aussi va travailler
avec les enfants sur le racket parce que
c'est un sujet qui leur tient vraiment à
coeur on a vu effectivement la
profession de foi du conseil municipal
c'est des sujets qui sont très
importants pour eux et pour réfléchir
avec eux sur le
le fait de leur dire vous avez le droit
de dire non vous avez complètement le
droit de dire non et les enfants et les
adultes se sont là pour vous aider voilà
donc il ya beaucoup d'ateliers qui sont
sous forme de jeu puisqu'il ya des jeux
de l'oie autour des droits de l'enfant
voilà il n'ya plus de 500 participants
qui viennent sur cette manifestation sur
lui en cours pardon du droit des enfants
je veux juste rappeler certains chiffres
qui sont inquiétants et qui concerne
uniquement la france 1 millions
d'enfants pauvres 19 mille enfants
maltraités cent cinquante mille enfants
qui quittent le système scolaire sans
perspectives et finalement on en parle
assez peu même si ça se déroulait ça se
passe en france et va pour toi les
droits de l'enfant ça représente quoi
avoir des droits ça veut dire quoi ça
présente enfin l'enfant est un être à
part entière
l'égalité
je sais pas si on message que vous
faites passer au avec tous les élus
jeunes
enfants rien que le fait qu'un conseil
municipal des enfants ça prouve que on a
des droits qu'on existe et puis
franchement moi j'aimerais passer un
message c'est que les droits des enfants
c'est dommage ça pas respecté les pays
et s'est jamais quelque chose d'acquis
malheureusement droits des enfants de
voir des enfants aussi oui oui dit c'est
vrai qu'il y ait aussi
bien les adultes en profite pour passer
le message le 20 novembre 89 les nations
unies adoptée donc ce texte de 54
articles sur les droits de l'enfant
l'unicef se bat pour les faire respecter
je vous propose de regarder ce spot
réalisé l'an dernier justement pour
sensibiliser
pour nous c'est l'enfer cette année 7
millions d'enfants sont morts
principalement de causes évitables avec
l'unicef continuons d'agir aidez nous
donner
les ministères qui a publié à l'occasion
de cette journée internationale des
droits de l'enfant un rapport sur les
enfants en france sur l'intégration
sociale des enfants en france c'est une
première ce rapport sur les 6 18 ans qui
ont été mis à contribution
elle 17 % des enfants sont en profond
mal être social 55 % des enfants ont
déjà connu une situation de harcèlement
en milieu scolaire et un enfant sur dix
ne se sent pas respectés par les adultes
vous nous parliez tout à l'heure du
racket dans leur profession de foi ces
jeunes parler de ses difficultés aussi
au quotidien à l'école c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui ont été confrontés à ce
genre de problème ou dans ton entourage
d'autres aussi ont parlé de mal être
social de harcèlement au milieu scolaire
de difficultés pas toujours facile
d'être un enfant non
c'est pas facile c'est puis c'est à cet
âge là c'est un peu un module plus fort
aussi
oui enfin ça m'est arrivé de vivre ça
c'est arrivé à des personnes que je
connais c'est
c'est malheureusement la vie
c'est pas facile pour tout le monde s'en
sortir et
souvent les les personnes en sont
les victimes peuvent devenir par la
suite les celles qui font subir le
harcèlement à d'autres personnes donc
là aussi avec le conseil municipal des
enfants pour passer ce message et les
aider si jamais vous souhaitez vous
sollicitez oui enfin il faut en parler
faut réagir parce que parfois on s'en
bat tout à fait compte de la gravité de
la situation et ça peut très vite
dégénérer merci à toutes et 2 est
revenue sur le plateau ont parlé des
droits de l'enfant ce soir et guyancourt
journée spéciale avec les enfants de la
ville c'est prévu vendredi merci à vous
une dernière information qui concerne
vos conditions de circulation demain
puisque un blocage est prévu par la
fédération départementale des
agriculteurs et sur les axes menant à
paris un cortège d'une cinquantaine de
tracteurs va prendre le départ vers 5
heures du matin à houdan dans le but de
rejoindre paris par la nationale 12 une
manifestation non autorisée qui a pour
but de demander la démission du ministre
de l agriculture vous le savez les
agriculteurs qui sont très en colère à
travers toute la france actuellement
merci donc à nos invités de ce soir le
journal est terminé pour aujourd'hui il
revient demain avec de nouveaux invités
sur ce plateau point complet sur
l'actualité locale des est 18h en direct
ce mercredi soir vous avez rendez vous
dans quelques instants avec aurélia de
bissy pour le nouveau numéro de kiosques
consacré à la culture bonne soirée